So today we're going to continue
our discussion of networking.
If you remember from
the last few times,
we talked about these two
different layers of the network
stack so far.
We talked about the
link layer, and we
talked about the network layer.
And today were going to talk
about the end to end layer.
So what we've
talked about so far
has been a network
stack that provides
this abstraction of being able
to send a message from one
machine to another machine
across a number of links
in the network.
And this network
stack that we talked
about is, if you will remember,
a best effort network.
So a best effort network,
as you'll remember,
is a network that is
subject to losses.
So some messages may not
be properly transmitted
from one point to
the other point.
It's subject to the possibility
of reordering of messages,
as messages may
take, for example,
different routes
through the network.
And it's subject to
delays and congestion
typically due to queuing
within the network.
So, today what we're going to
talk about it and end layer.
And the end to
end layer is going
to be the way that we're going
to get that finally addressing
some of these best effort
network properties we've
been kind of skirting around
for the last few lectures.
Particularly, today we're going
to focus on the issue of loss.
How do we avoid losses
within the network?
And we'll talk a little
bit about this problem
of reordering.
We're going to save the
discussion of delays
and congestion for next time.
So the end to end
layer in addition
to helping us deal with these
limitations of the best effort
network provides a
few other features
that we need to mention.
So, the first thing that
the end to end layer does
is it provides the ability to
multiplex multiple applications
on top of the network.
So the network that
we talked about so far
is one in which
there are these two
endpoints, to computers that
are connected to each other.
And they are transmitting
a sequence of messages.
But we haven't
really said anything
about how those
messages get dispatched
to different applications that
are running above the network
layer.
The other thing the
end to end layer
provides for us
is the ability to,
is fragmentation of messages.
OK, and fragmentation
is really about the fact
that the link in itself
may have some maximum size
message that it can physically
transmit because that's,
say for example, the
maximum size message
is how long the sender
and receiver can remain
synchronized with each other.
So what the end to
end layer often does
is it provides the ability
to take a longer message
and fragment it up into
smaller chunks or fragments,
and it transmits each
of those fragments
independently as a separate
message across the network.
So just to illustrate
how these things are
dealt with within
the end to end layer,
let's look at a
little illustration.
So suppose we have some set of
applications that are connected
up to the end to end layer.
OK, so these
applications, the idea
is going to be that when a
message arrives over the end
to end layer, it's
going to be dispatched
to one of these
applications by looking
at a special number that's in
the header of this message that
comes in.
So, this number is often
referred to as a port number.
And, each application
is going to be
running on one of these ports.
So oftentimes these
ports are sort
of running at
well-known addresses.
So we talked about these
numbers very briefly
earlier, for example, Web
servers run at port number 80
in the TCP protocol.
So if you want to contact a Web
server at a particular machine,
talk to port 80.
Other times applications
will send the port number
that they're listening at in a
message where two people will
exchange the port numbers
through some out of band
protocol, say by telling
your friend in an email
that he should connect
your server because it's
running on port X.
So, messages now
are going to arrive
into the end to end layer
from the network layer.
And these messages
are going to have
in their header information
about which port
they should be dispatched to.
So the other functionality of
the end to end layer I said
is fragmentation.
Then fragmentation is about
taking a message that's
being sent down from one
of these applications
into the end to end layer.
And then that message on
its way to the network layer
gets fragmented up into
a number of chunks.
So these are each of
these little chunks
in this message is
called a fragment.
So these are sort of, so
oftentimes one common end
to end layer is one that
provides an abstraction that's
called a stream.
So a stream is simply a
flow of messages or data
from one endpoint to the other,
one application to the other,
and where the segments in
that stream are guaranteed
to be delivered, are loss-free.
So there are no missing
segments or missing messages.
And they are in order.
So the application knows that
the data that it receives
is going to be in the order
that the receiver knows
the data it receives is
going to be in the order
that the sender sent
it out on the channel.
And there won't be
any missing messages.
So this sounds like a pretty
convenient abstraction.
And it's one that's often
used in applications.
And in fact, this
stream abstraction
is the attraction that
the TCP protocol provides.
OK, so just to sort
of make it clear,
I just want to look
quickly at a simplified end
to end header format.
So we looked at the header
formats at the other layers
last time.
And this is just showing
some of the things
that you might expect to
see an end to end header.
There are, of course,
are additional things
if you go look at
the TCP header.
But these are the
ones that mostly
matter from the point
of view of this class.
So there is a source
port which specifies
which port the
sender of the message
is listening at
on the other side.
There is a
destination port which
specifies which port
number this message
should be sent to on
the receiver side.
There is something
called the nonce.
The nonce is just a
unique identifier.
It's just a thing that uniquely
identifies this message
as far as the conversation
between the two endpoints
is concerned.
A common kind of
the nonce to use
is just a sequence
number that gets
incremented by one every time
an additional message is sent.
And then, oftentimes in
the end to end layer,
there's also some
check some information,
something that
allows you to verify
the integrity of the messages
that are transmitted out
over the network.
And we do this at
the end to end layer.
We saw that the checksum
sometimes appeared
in the link layer before.
They also appear at the end to
end layer because it's possible
that, as you guys read
in the paper about end
to end arguments,
oftentimes we want
to verify that the message is
correct at the end to end layer
or at the application layer
even if we have already
may be verified but that was
the case at the link layer
because the message could
have been corrupted somewhere
above just the
link layer, right?
So this is sort
of the abstraction
that the end to
end layer provides.
Notice that the header format
here doesn't actually include,
for example, the addresses
of the endpoints,
the IP addresses.
That's because the IP
addresses are in the IP header.
So, remember, this is just
the additional information
that's added by the
end to end layer,
and is used to
dispatch from the end
to end layer to the applications
that are running above it.
Once we are dealing with
the end to end header,
all the packets have
already been transmitted
across the network,
and in fact we
don't need to know what
the IP address is anymore
because this is happening
on the local machine.
All of the applications are
running at the same IP address.
OK, so that the other things
that we said, so I said today
we're going to focus mostly
on the ability of the end
to end layer to mitigate
these problems of losses.
So this is sort
of the abstraction
that the end to
end layer provides.
But what we want
to look at now is
how does the end to end layer
actually deal with loss?
We're going to talk about
two different techniques.
There's two different
components to dealing with loss.
So the first thing
we want to do is
we want to make sure
that no packets get
lost during transmission.
And the way we're
going to do that
is providing what we call
at least once delivery.
The reason I put at
least once in quotes
here is that I'm going to
talk you through a protocol.
But, and this protocol
is going to guarantee
that a message gets
received by the receiver
as long as, for example, the
receiver doesn't completely
fail or the network
doesn't completely explode.
So it's always
possible that messages
can be lost because there can
be some physical failure that
makes it impossible for the
messages to get through.
But as long as it is possible
for the message to get through,
there's a very high
probability that the message
will, in fact, get through.
And, if the message
doesn't get through,
what this at least once delivery
protocol is going to guarantee
is that the receiver knows
that the sender may not
have actually received
the message, OK?
So, and once we talk
about it at least once,
we're going to talk
about something
we call at most once delivery.
And the issue with at most once
delivery is the at least once
protocol that I'm
going to sketch out
is going to generate duplicates.
And we're going to need to
make sure that we can get rid
of some of the duplicates.
And these two
things together are
going to provide what's
known as exactly once
delivery of messages.
OK, so let's start
off by talking
about our at least
once protocol.
This protocol is
going to guarantee
that if at all possible,
the message will
be received by the receiver.
And the way we're
going to do this
is really very straightforward.
We are just going to have the
receiver send a message back
to the sender that
says I got the message.
So, the receiver, when
it gets the message,
sends what's called an
acknowledgment back --
-- sometimes abbreviated ACK,
indicating that the message was
received at the other end.
OK, this is just going to
be sent back to the receiver
directly.
So in order to send
this acknowledgment,
though, we're going to
need a way for the receiver
to refer to the message
that the sender sent, right?
So we want the receiver
to be able to say
I received this message
that you sent to me.
And the simplest way
to be able to do that
is to just use this
nonce information that's
in the packets.
We said the nonce is
a unique identifier
as far as the two endpoints of
the conversation are concerned.
So the knowledge
man is basically
just going to be the
nonce of the message, OK?
So let's look at how this
works in a simple example.
So the idea is that
the sender at some
point it's going to send
a message to the receiver.
And this message is going
to contain information
like, well, it's going to have
the address of the sender,
the address of the receiver, the
ports on both ends the message
is supposed to be sent to, this
nonce information that uniquely
identifies the message, and then
whatever the data that needs
to go in the message.
Now when it sends this
message, what's going to happen
is that the sender
is going to keep
this table of pending messages.
So the sender is going to keep
a list of all the messages
that it hasn't yet
heard acknowledged.
And then at some
point, and it's going
to keep, for example,
if this message is,
say, the name of
this message is one
and the nonce for
this message is X,
is going to add that
information into its table.
Now at some point
later the receiver
is going to send in a knowledge
man for this message one back.
And it just going to have
the sender and receiver IP
address, the port
number of the receiver,
and the nonce,
which the sender is
going to use in order to remove
this entry from its table.
So once the sender receives an
acknowledgment for a message,
it no longer needs to
keep any state about it
because it knows that the
receiver has received it.
OK, so how does
this do us any good?
How is this at least once?
Well, let's see what
happens when there is loss
that occurs within the network?
So the idea is very simple.
Suppose that the
sender sends out
a message, message
two this time,
and that message
somehow gets lost
in transit through the network.
So the network drops the message
either because of congestion
or because some links failed
and it doesn't get through.
The idea is that
the sender is going
to keep a timer associated with
every message that it sends.
And this timer is going to
be a timeout value that's
going to tell the sender
when it should retry
transmitting this message.
And the sender is just going
to retry transmitting messages
over and over and over again
until the message actually
gets through.
So in this case
it sets this timer
for time TR1 at the same instant
that it sends out this message.
And then when time TR1 arrives
in the message hasn't yet
been acknowledged,
the sender is,
so after this retry
interval time,
the sender is just going to
try and retransmit the message.
So now in this
case, the receiver
has successfully
received the message.
But notice that the
sender doesn't actually
know that the receiver
has received it.
We can see it from the
diagram, but there's
been no feedback that has
come from the receiver again.
And now, suppose that
the receiver sends
its acknowledgment for this
message, and along the way
the acknowledgment
gets lost, right?
So this could happen
just as easily
as the original
message being sent out.
So now in this case, our retry
mechanism continues to work.
And after this retry interval
and time TR2 is reached,
the message gets resent,
and then in this case
finally the message
is actually received
and we can go ahead and remove
from the pending message list.
So this process,
the sender is just
going to continually
retry transmitting
these messages until it
gets an acknowledgment
from the receiver.
Actually in practice,
it's the case
that the receiver will only
retry a fixed number of times
because as we said, there
are certain situations
in which the network can
just be simply unavailable.
Suppose there's no
network connection
available to the
transmitter to the sender.
Of course at some point it's
going to make sense for it
to give up and stop trying.
And then it will report
an error to the user.
The other thing to notice
about this protocol
that we've described here is
that the receiver has received
two copies of this message.
So that seems a little
bit problematic, right?
If this is a message that says
withdraw $10,000 from your bank
account, we don't probably want
to process that message twice,
right?
That might be problematic.
So we're going to
address that issue
when we get to talking
about at most once delivery.
But just bear in mind for
now that these duplicates
can occur.
There is another subtlety
with this protocol that I've
described here, though.
Does anybody see
something that's
a little bit suspicious
about this diagram
that I've shown here, a little
bit weird about the way I've
shown it?
Yeah?
OK, right, good.
So there's this
question about, how
are you going to set the retry
interval for these messages,
right?
So what I've shown here is that
the retry interval is short,
and the first time we sent and
received this message, in fact
the time it took us to do
that appeared to be quite
long on this diagram, right?
And so in fact what would've
happened if we had done
this is that the sender would
have retransmitted this message
several times even though the
receiver had actually received
the message, and
the acknowledgment
was on the way back
to us correctly.
It's just that we
didn't wait long enough
for that acknowledgment
to come back to us.
So, there's this
question about, well,
how are we going to pick this
timer interval so that it's
appropriate for the network
that we're running on.
And this turns out to be kind of
an interesting and challenging
problem.
So there's this
question about, how long
do I wait before a retry?
So a simple answer for
how long we should wait
is, well, whatever the
round-trip time on the network
is, however long it takes for
a message to reach the receiver
and then for the knowledge meant
to be sent back to the sender;
so we call that the
round-trip time up or the RTT.
So, we'd like to wait
at least RTT, right?
But the problem is that
RTT is this round-trip time
is not necessarily going to
be constant over the whole
lifetime of the network.
So let me show you what I mean.
This is a plot of some
round-trip time information
from a wide area wireless link.
So these transit
times are very long
here over this link,
their sort of order
of thousands of milliseconds.
So the average transmission
time is 2.4 seconds here.
The standard deviation,
which is a measure
of the variance between
these different samples
is 1.5 seconds.
So there's a lot of bouncing
around of this signal.
And so it's not as though
the round-trip time;
expecting the round-trip
time to simply
be a single constant value
isn't a very good idea.
So if we want to
set the timeout just
for RTT, that's
going to cause us,
if you think about
this for a minute,
if we set it just to be RTT,
which is say for example may be
the average round-trip
time that we measured
in a signal like this, well,
some significant proportion
of the time we're going to
be above the RTT, right,
because just
picking the average,
there's going to be many
samples that are above the RTT.
So instead we want to
do RTT plus some slop
value, some
adjustment factor that
gives us a little bit of extra
sort of leeway in how long
we wait.
But of course we
don't want to wait
too long because if
we wait too long then
we're not going to actually
retransmit the messages that
were in fact lost.
OK, so let's look
at how, so that's
sort of a simple
intuitive argument
for how we should do this.
What I want to just do now
is just quickly take you
through the way that these
round-trip times are done,
actually, these
round-trip times are
estimated in the TCP protocol.
And the way this is done is
really pretty straightforward.
The idea is that we want to
estimate the average RTT.
And then we also
want to estimate
the sort of variance which is
going to be our slop number.
OK, so one way we could
compute the average RTT
is to keep this sort
of set of samples
of all the round-trip times.
So I have maybe
20 points, I have
whatever it is, 20
points here that are
samples of the round-trip time.
So I could take this
set of 20 numbers
and compute the average of them.
And then I could recompute
the average every time
a new number comes in.
The problem with
that is that I have
to keep this window of
all the averages around.
So instead, what
we want to do is
to have some way
of sort of updating
the average without
having to keep
all the previous values around.
And there's a simple
technique that's commonly
used in computer systems called
an exponentially weighted
moving average, which
is a way that we
can keep track of this average
with just a single number.
So this is the EWMA.
And what the EWMA does is
given a set of samples,
say S1 up to some
most recent sample S
gnu, what the EWMA
does is incrementally
adjust the RTT according
to the following formula.
So, as the [new/gnu?] RTT is
going to be equal to one minus
alpha, so these samples are
samples of round-trip times,
OK, like this number here.
So, these are
numbers that we have
observed over time as
messages have been transmitted
back and forth.
We're going to take some
number one minus alpha times S
gnu, our newly observed
roundtrip time.
And we're going to add
to that some alpha times
the old round-trip time.
OK, so what this
does is basically
it computes the RTT as
some weighted combination
of the old roundtrip time and
the newly observed roundtrip
time.
And, if you think about this
for a minute, if we make alpha,
so alpha in this case is going
to be some number between zero
and one.
And if you think about alpha
being zero, if alpha is zero,
then the newly computed
round-trip time
is just equal to S gnu, right?
And, if alpha is one, then the
newly computed roundtrip time
is just equal to whatever the
old round-trip time was, right?
So, the new sample
has no effect.
So, as we move very alpha
between these two extremes,
we are going to weight the new
roundtrip time more or less
heavily.
OK, so this is not going to
perfectly compute the average
of the samples over time.
But it's going to give
us some estimate that
sort of varies with time.
The other thing we
said we wanted to do
was compute what
the slop factor is.
And the slop
factor, we just want
this to be some measure of
the variance of this signal.
So in particular, what
we want it to be is,
I'm just going to push
this up so I can write,
slop is going to be
equal to some factor
beta times some variants
of this, some number
that the variance.
And what I mean by
variance is simply
the difference between the
predicted and actual round-trip
times.
So if our formula says that
this round-trip time, given
a sample, the round-trip
time should be 10 ms.
And the next sample
comes in and it
says the actual
round-trip time was 20 ms.
Then the variance, we would say
that sort of this deviation,
the difference between those
two things would be 10 ms.
So let's see how this works.
I'll show you now the
pseudocode for how this actually
works in the Internet.
And it should be pretty
clear what's going on.
So what we're going
to do is we are
going to keep a set of
variables, one of which
is called SRTT.
So this is almost exactly
what the TCP protocol does.
So we're going to have SRTT,
which is the current roundtrip
time estimate.
And then we're going to have
this thing we're going to call
RTT [DEV?], which
is the deviation,
the current estimate of sort of
the variance of this round-trip
time.
And we're going to
initialize these two
numbers to be something
that seems reasonable.
We might say the
round-trip time is 100 ms,
and this RTT DEV is 50 ms.
And now what we're
going to do is
every time a new one of these
samples of the round-trip time
comes in, we're going to
call this calc RTT function.
What the calc RTT
function is going
to do isn't going
to update the old,
update the round-trip
time using this formula
that we've seen here.
And in the case of TCP, people
have sort of experimented
with different values, and sort
of the number that is typically
used is that a number
that is commonly used
is that sort of used alpha, you
set alpha to be seven eighths.
So that means that you
sort of add in one eighth
of the new number, and use
seven eighths of the old number.
So, a new number
that varies a lot
isn't going to change the
overall round-trip time,
estimate of the round-trip
time terribly dramatically.
And we're going to compute the
deviation as I've shown here.
We're going to take the
absolute value of it.
And then, we're going to
keep some running estimate
of the round-trip
time again using
one of these sort of
exponentially weighted things.
So in this case
we're going to wait
with this setting, the
value of the weight
here to three quarters.
OK, so that's a simple way to
compute the round-trip time.
And now, given the computation
of the round-trip time, what
we need to do is to
compute the timeout value
that we should use.
So what we said is the
timeout value you want to use
is RTT plus some slop.
And, in the case of TCP,
a commonly used slop value
might be four times the
estimate of the deviation.
See, the idea is
that we want the slop
value to be larger if the
round-trip time varies more.
If the round-trip time
is practically constant,
we don't want it to vary much.
We are sort of happy; if the
round-trip time is practically
constant, then the timeout
shouldn't be very much longer
than that round-trip
time because that's
going to suggest we are
going to be waiting longer
than we need to time out.
If the round-trip time
varies very dramatically,
we need to wait a relatively
long time in order
to be sure that
the message in fact
has been lost as
opposed to simply taking
a long time for
the acknowledgment
to get back to us.
OK, so what we've
seen so far now
is we've seen how we can build
up at least once semantics
using acknowledgments.
And we talked about how we can
go ahead and set these timers
in order to allow us to
calculate the round-trip time
for a message.
And these timers are going to
allow us to sort of decide when
we should retransmit a message.
But we also saw how we have
a little bit of a problem
in the at least once protocol.
And the problem is that we
can generate duplicates.
So in order to
avoid duplicates, we
need to introduce this
notion of at most once.
OK, so the idea
with at most once
is that we want to
suppress duplicates.
And duplicate suppression turns
out it works a lot like the way
that acknowledgments
work on the receiver side
or on the sender side.
So on the receiver
side we're going
to keep a table of
all of the nonces,
of all the messages
that we've heard,
and we're only going to process
a message when we haven't
already processed that message.
And we're going to tell whether
we've already processed it
by looking in this
table of nonces.
So let's look at an example.
So here we are.
This is sort of showing
you the protocol,
a stage in the at
least once protocol
that we were in before.
So we've already
sent message one.
It's been successfully
acknowledged.
And you notice that we
have this table of nonces,
received messages, that
is that the receiver.
And in this table, we
have received this message
with nonce X.
OK, so now when
the sender starts
to decide to send a message two
with nonce Y, it sends it out.
The message doesn't arrive.
We time out.
We retry.
And this time the message
is successfully received.
So what we do is we go ahead and
add the nonce for this message
into the table on the receiver.
And then the receiver goes ahead
and sends the acknowledgment.
But the acknowledgment is lost.
Again, the sender times
out, resends the message.
And this time, when the
receiver receives this message,
it's going to look it up in
the receive messages table.
And it's going to see
that this is a duplicate.
It already has seen a
message with nonce Y.
So, it's not going
to process this.
But it needs to
still be sure that it
sends the acknowledgment
of the message.
So it doesn't
actually do anything.
It doesn't actually
process this message.
It doesn't pass it
up to the application
so the application
can look at it.
But it still sends
the acknowledgment
so that the receiver knows that
the message has been received.
OK, so this is fine.
But if you think about
this for a second,
this table of received
messages is now
just going to be kind of
growing without bound, right?
Because every time
we receive a message,
we're going to add a new message
to this table of nonces, right?
And this is a problem.
I mean if we're sending
thousands of messages
out over the network,
then this table
is going to become
very, very large.
So what are we going
to do about it?
Well, we're going to do sort
of again the obvious thing.
We're going to have
the sender send
some additional
information that lets
the receiver know which messages
the receiver has actually
heard.
So a common way that
this might be done
is to simply, along
with each message that
gets sent, piggyback a
little bit of information,
for example that contains
the list of messages
that the sender knows that the
receiver has actually received.
Right, so when the sender
receives an acknowledgment
for a message, it
knows that it's never
going to have to
request, never going
to resend the message anymore.
And so there's no
reason for the receiver
to keep that message in its
table of received messages
because it's never going
to be asked to acknowledge
that message again.
So we can attach a little bit
of information to the messages
that we send that indicates
sort of which messages we
have definitely completed
up to this point.
OK, so this is a
simple way in which
we can sort of eliminate
these messages that
are hanging around.
These messages that
are sort of left
in our table of
received messages
are sometimes referred
to as tombstones,
which is kind of a funny name.
But the idea is that there
are these messages that
are kind of, that
are sort of remnants
of a dead message that's
hanging around that we're never
going to need to process again.
But it might just be
sitting in this table.
And we are able to get rid
of some of the tombstones
by piggybacking this information
on to the ends of the messages
that we retransmit.
But you have to realize
that there's always
going to be a few messages left
over in this receive messages
table because if we use
this piggybacking technique
because we are piggybacking
a list of done messages
onto messages that are sent.
So if the sender never
sends any more messages,
then the receiver
is never going to be
able to eliminate
any of the tombstones
from its list of
received messages.
OK, so now what we've
seen is a simple way
to provide this sort of notion
of at least once and at most
once delivery.
So as I said before,
taken together,
this is sometimes called
an exactly once protocol.
And this variant of this
protocol that we've seen
is called a lockstep protocol.
OK, so it's called lockstep
because the sender and receiver
are operating in lockstep.
The sender sends a
message, and then it
waits for the receiver to send
in a knowledge meant before it
sends any additional messages.
Right, so we are always sort
of sitting here waiting for,
the sender is basically
spending a lot of time
idle waiting to receive
an acknowledgment.
If you think about
what this means
in terms of the
throughput of the network,
it's kind of a limitation.
So let's do a
simple calculation.
So suppose that we said that
packets, the segments that
are being sent in this network,
these things that are being
sent back and forth
in being acknowledged
are, say, 512 bytes large.
So, suppose we
said that it takes
the round-trip
time in the network
is, say, 100 ms, which
might be a common roundtrip
time in a traditional
network, well, the throughput
of this network is going to
be, the maximum throughput
be limited by this number,
512 bytes divided by 100 ms.
The round-trip time is 100 ms.
And so we have to wait 100
ms between each transmission
of messages.
And the sort of
size of a message
is, if the message is
512 bytes, then we're
going to be able to send ten
of these messages per second.
So we're going to send sort of
approximately 50 kb per second.
OK, that's not very fast, right?
If we want to send,
modern networks
are often capable of sending
tens or hundreds of megabytes,
megabits a second.
So we would like to be able
to make this number higher.
So this is a bit of a
performance problem.
And the way we're
going to do this
is by making it so
that the sender doesn't
wait to receive its
acknowledgments before it goes
and sends the next message.
So the sender is going to
start sending the next message
before it's even heard
the first message even
being acknowledged.
So we're going to have multiple
overlapping transmissions, OK?
So let's see a really simple
example of how this works.
So the idea is now
that the sender,
it's going to send a message.
And then before it's even
heard the knowledge meant
from the receiver, it's
going to go ahead and start
sending the message.
At the same time,
the receiver can
go ahead and
acknowledge the messages
that have already been sent.
So you sort of see
what's happening
here is that as time passes, the
additional messages are being
sent, and the acknowledgment
for those messages
start being sent as
soon as possible.
So we have a whole
bunch of messages
that are kind of flying back
and forth within this network.
And I've only shown the sort of
yellow, red, and blue messages
actually being
acknowledged here.
The white messages aren't
being acknowledged.
But of course there would be
acknowledgments [pulling?]
for those as well.
So this seems really good.
Right now we can send
messages basically
as fast as we can cram
them onto the network.
And we sort of don't have to
wait for the acknowledgments
to come back anymore.
So in effect, what
we've said is now
the throughput is
simply constrained
by how fast we can cram
the bytes onto the network.
But this is a little bit of
an oversimplification, right,
because this is sort
of ignoring what
it is that the receiver, suppose
the sender is just sending data
as fast as it can.
Well the receiver has
to receive that data,
has to do something with it.
It has to process it.
It has to take some
action on it, right?
And so it's very possible
or very likely in fact
that if we cram data at
the receiver in this way,
that the receiver is going
to become overloaded, right?
The receiver has
some limited amount
of data that it can buffer
or that it can hold on to.
And we are going to
overflow those buffers.
And we're going to
create a problem.
So what we want to do
is to have some way
to allow the receiver
to kind of throttle
the transmission of the
sender to ask the sender
to back off a little bit,
and not send so aggressively.
So we call this --
-- the technique that we're
going to use is called flow
control.
And it's basically just a
way in which the receiver
can tell the sender
what great it
would like to receive data at.
OK, so this is going to be sort
of receiver driven feedback.
And we're going to
look at two techniques
basically for doing this.
The first one is a technique
called fixed windows.
And the other technique
is a technique
called sliding windows.
OK, and what we
mean by window here:
a window is simply the size of
the data that the receiver can
accept, the number of messages
that the receiver can accept --
-- can accept at one time.
So the idea is we're going to
send a window's worth of data
all continuously.
And then once the
receiver says that it's
done processing
that window, we're
going to be able to go ahead
and send a next window to it.
So this first scheme that
we're going to look at
is called the fixed
windows scheme.
And the idea is really
very straightforward.
The sender and the receiver at
the beginning of communication
can negotiate.
They're going to
exchange some information
about what the window size is.
So the sender is
going to request
the connection,
the open, and then
the receiver is going to say,
for example, OK, let's go ahead
and start having this
conversation, and by the way,
my window size is four segments.
So now, the sender can send
four segments all at once,
and the receiver can go
ahead and acknowledge them.
So we can have four segments
that are sort of in flight
at any one time.
And then after those messages
have all been acknowledged,
the receiver is going to have to
sort of chew on those messages
and process them for a little
while, during which time
basically the sender
is simply waiting.
It's simply sitting
there waiting.
But notice that we
were at least able to,
the sender was able to do
a little bit of extra work.
It was able to send all
four of these messages
to simultaneously.
And then when the
receiver has finished
processing these
messages, it's going
to go ahead and ask for some
additional set of messages
to be transmitted
out over the network.
So notice that there is
a little assumption here
which is that acknowledgments
are being sent
before the sort of
receiver has actually
finished processing
the messages.
So the protocol that
I'm showing here
is that the receiver
receives a message,
and it immediately
acknowledges it without,
even though it hasn't
actually, the application
hasn't necessarily
processed this message yet.
And the reason we want to
do this is that application
process, remember it's
already hard enough for us
to estimate this round-trip
time using this EWMA approach.
And so, trying to
sort of also estimate
how long it would take the
application to process the data
would further complicate this
process of setting timers.
So we usually just sending
knowledge meant right away.
OK, so this is the fixed
size windows scheme.
And it's nice
because now basically
we've set this thing up so that
the sender can sort of send
more messages without waiting
for the acknowledgments.
But the receiver has a way
that it can kind of throttle
how fast the sender sends.
It knows that it only has
buffers for four messages.
So it says my
window size is four.
But we would like to do a
little bit better, right?
In particular, we would like
to avoid this sort of situation
where, both so in this case we
sort of have long periods where
the network is kind
of sitting idle,
where we are not using available
bandwidth within the network
because we're sort of waiting.
The sender has,
perhaps, data to send,
but it hasn't received
the message to send,
the receiver can
accept more messages.
And the receiver may be has
processed some of the messages
that it's received, but it
hasn't yet sent this message;
it hasn't yet asked the
sender to go ahead and send
any additional data.
So the way that we're going to
fix this is to use something
called the sliding
window technique.
And the idea is that when
the receiver, rather than
the receiver waiting until it
is processed the whole window's
worth of data, when
the receiver processes
each message within its window,
so if this window is more
messages big, once it's
processed the first message,
it's going to go ahead and
indicate that to the sender
so that the sender can
then go ahead and send
additional messages.
So rather than sort of
getting four new messages
at a time, what
we're going to do
is we're going to send
our first four messages.
And then we're going to just
send one additional message
at a time.
So that's why we say the window
is sliding, because we're
going to sort of
allow the sender
to send an additional
message whenever
it is that the receiver is
finished processing just one
message.
And the way we are
going to do this again,
we're going to initially
negotiate a window size.
And then when the
sender starts sending,
it's going to do the same thing.
It's going to send all
four of these messages.
I've sort of halted this
animation in the middle of it
so that I can show you
an intermediate step.
But what would really
be happening here
is the sender would sort of
send all the messages that
were in the window,
and then the receiver
would begin processing them.
So the receiver begins
processing the first message.
So suppose it finishes
processing segment one
before it receives this
segment two from the sender.
So now what it can do is in its
acknowledgment for segment two,
it can piggyback
again using this idea,
it can stick a little
bit of information
on to the knowledge meant
that says, oh, and by the way,
I have finished processing
one of these messages.
You can go ahead and send
one more additional message.
You can slide the
window by one, OK?
So I'm going to hit the
next step of this animation.
And it's going to
zip by really fast.
I'll explain what's
happening, but don't
try and worry too much about
exactly following the details.
OK, so now what happens is that
the receiver sort of continues
to process these
messages as it arrives,
and then it continues
to piggyback
this information about the fact
that it has finished sending
some messages onto
the acknowledgments,
finished processing
some messages
onto the acknowledgments.
If the receiver doesn't have
any acknowledgments to send,
which is the case for
these last two messages
that it sent out here that
I've labeled send more,
it may need to send
these sort of slide
the window messages out by
itself without acknowledgment.
So here it sends a couple
of additional messages
that say go ahead and
send me some more data.
OK so in this way
now what we've done
is we've managed to make
it so that the sender can
send additional
information before all
of the sort of messages
in the initial window
were processed by the receiver.
So you see that before
the sender sends,
before the receiver
actually requests,
sends a message requesting a
whole new window worth of data,
so you see now that some of
the sort of, go ahead and send
more messages from
the receiver arrive
at the sender after the time
that the sender starts sending
messages, this fifth and
sixth message to go ahead
and processed.
So we've managed
to sort of increase
the amount of
concurrent processing
that we can do in this network.
But there still
are periods where
the network is
sort of idle where
the sender and receiver are
sort of not transmitting data.
So we haven't done quite as good
a job as maybe we would like.
And the reason we haven't done
quite as good a job as maybe we
would like is when
the receiver, so
the property that we
would like to enforce
is that when the receiver
says go ahead and send me
a new message.
When the receiver says
slide the window by one,
by the time that the
next message to process
arrives from the sender,
we would like the receiver
to not have reached the
point where it's idle,
where it has to wait.
So we'd like the
receivers buffered
to be big enough such that by
the time its request for more
data reaches the sender,
and by the time the sender's
response comes back, we would
like the receiver to still
have some data to process,
whereas what's happened here
is that the receiver
finished processing all four
messages in its buffer before
this next message came back
with additional data
for the receiver
to process from the sender.
Right, so basically the problem
was that the receiver's buffer
wasn't quite large enough for
it to be able to continuously
process data; it didn't
have quite enough data
for it to be able to
continuously process
while it waited for
the additional data
to arrive from the sender.
What this suggests
that we want is
to set this buffer size, to
set the size of the window
to be the appropriate size
in order for the receiver
to be able to sort of
continuously process
information if at all possible.
So there's this question about,
how do we pick the window size?
So let's assume, so
the problem we have
is that small windows
imply underutilization
of the network,
OK, because we have
both the sender and receiver
sort of sitting, waiting.
There's times when there's no
data that's being transferred
across the network.
So the question is then, how
big should we make the window?
And what we said is we want the
window size to be greater than
the amount of time --
We want it to be long enough
so that the receiver which,
say for example, if the
receiver can processed
some number of messages,
rate messages per second,
OK, the receiver can
process this many messages,
we want its buffer
to be large enough
that if it processes that
many messages per second,
that the amount of time for
additional messages for it
to process, that it
will still have messages
to process by the time
additional messages arrive
from the sender.
So the amount of time it
takes for additional messages
to arrive from the
sender from the time
that this guy first since this
OK to send more message, right,
is one round-trip
time of the network.
So it takes one round-trip time
of the network for the receiver
to receive additional messages
to process from the sender,
and a number of messages
that will process
during that round-trip time is
whatever its message processing
rate is times the round-trip
time of the network.
And so, therefore,
this is sort of ideally
how we would set the window
size in this network.
Of course, we talked
about before how
it's tricky to estimate
this sort of EWMA thing
that we do to estimate
the window size
is not a perfect estimator.
But we're going to
try and sort of, this
is going to be a good choice
for a window size to use.
And so, typically
the receiver is
going to try and sort of use
some rough estimate of what
it thinks the round-trip time
is and the rate at which it
can process messages when it
informs the sender, the window
size at the initiation
of the connection.
OK, so this basically
is going to wrap up
our discussion of the end-to-end
layer, or of the sort of loss
recovery issues in
the end to end layer.
What we're going to talk about
next time is this issue of how
we deal with congestion, right?
So we said that in
one of these networks,
there can be all these
delays due to queuing,
and that these delays can
introduce additional loss.
And we call these
delays congestion.
And so what we're going
to talk about next time
is how we actually
deal with congestion
and how we respond
to congestion.
OK so we'll see
you on Wednesday.